KFC is one of the most classic fast-food
restaurants in the world with over
21,000 restaurants in over 130 countries
however since Colonel Sanders died the
company has actually been on a rapid
decline due to a variety of reasons and
in 2013 she clearly actually passed KFC
has the leading chicken retailer in the
US with half the amount of locations but
recently KFC has been able to make a
comeback so why didn't KFC fail in the
first place and will he be able to
reclaim their position as number one
chicken retailer make sure stick around
till the end to find out welcome to
Horry sorry Harland Sanders or Colonel
Sanders was actually born in a small
town outside of Henryville Indiana in
1890 his father died when he was at a
very young age and as a result his
mother had to go out and find a word and
this for Sanders to cook and take care
of his two younger siblings he ended up
leaving the family house when he was
just 13 years old and would find himself
in a lot of different professions
finding varying levels of success in
1930 at the age of 40 he took over a
shelf illustration on u.s. route 25 this
restaurant was fly outside North Corbin
Kentucky and this is where he first
served his food that you learn as a kid
to travelers he was most famous for
fried chicken steak and country ham for
the first four years he actually served
from his own dining table until he
bought a large and filling station on
the other side of the road he only had
six tables but the food did all the
talking
in fact by 1936 Governor Ruby lafoon
named him as the Kentucky kernel in 1937
he expanded his restaurant to comrade
for 142 seats he also purchased a motel
across the street he named his
restaurant Sanders Court and cafe at the
time it would actually take a long
duration of time to fry chicken on a
frying pan up to 35 minutes and he
refused to deep-fry the chicken as he
thought that this would lower the
quality of the chicken so he actually
ended up pre-cooking in the chicken we
selected a lot of wastage at the end of
the day but soon enough in 1939 the
first commercial pressure cooker was
least on sham market now this was a
really designed to steam vegetables but
he bought this and modified to the fried
chicken he said that this reduced the
time making comparable to the time of a
deep fryer but still retained the same
taste in 1940 he finalized what would be
known as his original recipe he also
started acting like a colonel watching
the way he dressed and going cote
Sandra's corn Cafe would Julia serve
travelers were passing by the town but
in 1955 this town would get bypassed
where Sanders did now was sell
everything that you own in the town and
start following the United States to try
to franchise the chicken recipe too many
restaurants in 1952 he was successful
franchising recipe this friend Pete
Harmon in Utah Don Anderson a sign
painter that Harmon I hired suggested
named Kentucky Fried Chicken he thought
this sounded very exotic and interesting
and as a result he named it Kentucky
Fried Chicken and this is how the first
KFC was born Harmon actually ended up
trademarking the phrase it's finger
lickin good this would eventually become
the company-wide slogan in 1957 he
introduced the bucket meal this would
consist of 14 pieces of chicken 5 bread
rolls and a pint of gravy
which would all be served in a cardboard
bucket and the bucket and the meal would
both become signature of KFC by 1963
they would have 600 KFC locations making
them the largest food chain in America
at the time they really popularized
chicken which challenge the dominance of
the burger and by 1964 Sandra's able to
sell the company to a group of investors
for two million dollars but he did place
a lot of contingencies he wanted to
remain the company's quality controller
and trademark and he wanted a lifetime
salary they agreed to these rules and by
1970 they had over 3,000 locations in 48
different countries and in July of 1971
the investor saw the company to blame
for 285 million dollars they definitely
got a great return out of KFC in 1980
unfortunately Colonel Sanders passed
away and just two years later boo Blaine
will be required by r.j. Reynolds and in
July of nineteen
six Reynolds would sell KFC at PepsiCo
for 850 million dollars
PepsiCo made a part of its restaurant
division along with Taco Bell and Pizza
Hut and these three companies were later
make up Tricon global brands which
eventually renamed as Yum Brands so far
KFC had been growing pretty rapidly but
after a death of Colonel Sanders it
simply would not be the same anymore
after the death of Colonel Sanders a
company completely ditched Colonel
Sanders and his red and white stripes in
terms of marketing instead they focused
on ads and featured younger customers
Mickey and looked up KFC was young and
hip they even introduced a cartoon
Sanders in the 1990s executives today
said this was an embarrassing misstep
and in 1991 they changed your name from
Kentucky Fried Chicken to kerosene now
they did this in an effort to go away
from fried products and make it sound
more healthy Plus this is already a
commonly used abbreviation so it wasn't
that weird but this led to rumors saying
the company changed your name as their
chicken was not actual real chicken this
led to a lot of bad publicity a bug
genetically modified chickens called
Franken chickens he had her a lot of new
menu items trying to make themselves
look more healthy or at least move away
from the chicken products one of these
attempts was to Double Down which is
basically a sandwich but the bread was
replaced with burgers now I'm not really
sure how this tasted but the taste
wasn't really the issue right here the
problem was that they were moving away
from what people were used to at KFC
they stopped focusing on the menu items
that they were actually known for and
what I should drove traffic they spread
themselves too thin focusing on new menu
items instead of trying to erase the bad
image about their main menu items and
this gave KFC and their food a really
bad reputation there has also been
rising competition over the last two
decades in 2016 chick-fil-a restaurant
sold three times as much as KFC
locations
chick-fil-a his sales per restaurant was
a whopping 3.1 million dollars this
number can be attributed to their much
better reputation
as they're known for great customer
service and an excellent mix of food
chick-fil-a has consistently ranked
number one for customer service and
people just loved their cleanliness
meanwhile customers have been
complaining about the food and KFC for
the past 25 years they claim that the
taste of KFC chicken has been
consistently going down for the past two
decades
they say that KFC just doesn't taste
like KFC anymore on top of this KMZ
plaques are generally just a bit more
expensive than other fast-food
restaurants and with quality enterprise
declining people don't want to pay a
higher price for a worse product it
seems to me that KFC has become more of
corporate carrying more of our profits
than actually providing a great customer
experience which is actually what will
help their bottom line
executives realized that KFC was going
down the wrong path and they knew they
had to make changes fairly quickly so in
2015 they went out and recalibrated all
the pressure fries across the US and an
effort to improve the quality of the
chicken and they spent more than a
100,000 hours repeating over 20,000
employees they held 43 general rallies
across the u.s. which 97% of general
managers of KFC's attended they also had
creating events at every single KFC in
the United States since then KFC claims
a taste course have significantly across
across America there are eternal ization
process was working and not why did a
boost customer interest but also their
satisfaction but that wasn't it they all
had other means to boost employee
performance over the past three years
they have been a huge remodeling push
remodeling 70 percent up in restaurants
which is about 3,000 stores in the
United States these redesign locations
are reportedly getting reduced turnover
rates and the signs of the kitchen
saying may the colonel proud have really
reinvigorated this staff so at this
point their overall customer experience
was really good now they need to get the
word out about KFC and to accomplish
this they're actually bringing back the
Colonel Sanders image in 2015 they
released a star comedian Darrell Hammond
as Colonel Sanders now this did the
response not all of which was good but
KFC claims that 80% was
positive but despite that I'm sure this
commercial touched hundreds of thousands
of people's lives and encouraged them to
go give KFC another shot
since then they have added more
comedians and produced more commercials
and the negative criticism has largely
died down these commercials have
accumulated millions of views and really
have made KFC popular once again the
British ad company unruly background KFC
as the most shared food brand a couple
of years ago an executive said they no
longer try to convince people that fried
chicken is healthy as it is just not
true rather there are more focus on
actually convincing people that their
food is real food not Franken chickens
and bringing in Colonel Sanders has
largely aid in their process of
convincing people that this is authentic
food and all of these efforts have led
to create same store sales growth and
last year KFC Jose bode record on the
best growth years in several years I
think we can definitely say that KFC is
back KFC was one of the most
recognizable restaurants in the late
1900s starting with very modest roots
however there are acquired by logic
corporations that lost our authentic
tastes and replayed for bad service but
recently KFC has made significant
changes and are growing faster than ever
before
well I can't say that KFC will surpass
chick-fil-a as chick-fil-a is absolutely
destroyed out there I can't confidently
say that KFC is back and they're here to
stay but that's all I have for you guys
on KFC you can I just hear about our
expansion out attack the u.s. they make
sure comment that down below also if you
guys like this video they mentioned up a
like and consider subscribing if you let
us see more videos just like this one
but for then uhnari
I'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]